the president largely ignored the
courtroom drama at a campaign style
rally in West Virginia last night
instead he repeated familiar attacks on
the Russia investigation fake news of
the Russian witch-hunt we got a whole
big combination where is the collusion
you know they're still looking for
collusion where is the collusion major
Garrett is at the White House with what
the legal outcomes mean for the
president and that very question he's
posing major good morning good morning
those close to the president described
him as feeling under siege not from
critics he's certainly used to that but
from events he can either control nor
fully anticipate and the plea agreement
reached by former friend fixer an
attorney Michael Cohen falls distinctly
into that category why because it
undercuts previous denials about
knowledge of campaign hush money and
suggests the Trump campaign had
knowledge of and at some level
participated in Cohen's now confessed
misdeeds aboard Air Force One last night
on the way to West Virginia the
president watched television coverage of
the man afford convictions and brooded
about their future potential impact
legally they're not troublesome directly
for the president but they do give a
sense that the Muller investigation is
both serious and legally competent and
that could undercut some of the
president's increasingly strident
criticism of Muller and his team now the
president's only real option is as one
close associate said pretend he never
knew man afford or Cohen that will be
difficult their relationships fully
well-documented another complication for
the president in this midterm political
climate the number of people close to
him who have either pled guilty been
convicted or implicated in wrongdoing
continues to multiply now back in June
the president said it was too early to
think about or discuss pardons for Cohen
or mana for nothing from the President
or the White House on that topic after a
day of sensational legal setbacks John
thank you major major let me ask you
this
it was after Nixon was named an
unindicted co-conspirator that he
eventually resigned to the presidency
not wanting to face impeachment what is
the sort of buzz around there what are
you picking up from your sources both on
Capitol Hill and the White House about
concerns about impeachment
well those concerns are in abeyance
until the midterm elections there's no
sense Republicans are going to jump into
that conversation and Democrats have
even been reluctant to bring that out
forward as an aggressive part of their
campaign to take control of the house in
the midterm elections but if that change
of power does occur it becomes a very
real live and politically dangerous and
potentially legally legal danger legally
dangerous rather threat for the
president major let me ask you about the
Cohen news this is a president who
prizes loyalty above any other virtue
the michael cohen was his close consul
Gary he is now pointing the finger at
the president so that would seem to
muddle any question of pardons but just
from an emotional standpoint does that
create a different case here with Cohen
than say any of the others from his
administration who fled or have been
found guilty those I talk to about this
yesterday John just described the
President as pained very deeply pained
several associates described Cohen as a
rat now let me tell you Michael Cohen
spent a lot of time around Trump Tower
during the campaign you could scarcely
move in or out of Trump Tower without
bumping into Michael Cohen he was an
associates associate so close and deeply
involved and devoted to and loyal to the
president his campaign everything about
the Trump Organization that shift away
from that loyalty and now not just
pleading guilty but pleading guilty to
things that bring legal issues right to
the doorstep of the president and his
campaign is an act of legal significance
it's actually a deeply painful one for
the president and what he thought was an
ironclad relationship of loyalty with
Cohen all right major thank you so much